but the casting does seem perfect the
the four of you as a kind of you know
Falls yeah we think so sure I assume the
dysfunctional purveyor of tough love
just sloppy sentimental brimming over
with emotion and is that you well it's a
serve extreme version of me I'm I'm a
little bit sentimental myself you know
[Music]
they're always crying I can myself
crying on a commercial airline flight
watching The Parent Trap my wife looked
over me it's like what is going on and
I'm like cuz you know you know what's
gonna happen they're all gonna get back
together but I just I couldn't help it
tears were just streaming down my face
John apparently you made yourself cry in
a plane I was watching terms of
endearment for the first time in many
years a movie that I was in
[Applause]
I'm so damn good
you're breaking my heart
damn you John let's go give it to me
again in terms of endearment is all
that's so obsessive it's a completely is
sort of no-fault tearjerker
it never fails I'm more but I've heard
you saying that as you get older you are
getting more emotional you do more more
boo-hooing yes pretty even really even
Disney's got to you now do tell didn't
you cry watching a film with your kids
or maybe you weren't watching with your
kids maybe you're just watching it I
don't know I have I know I I get very
sentimental you know that the biggest
ads that get me now yes shrek makes me
cry
I was Lord Farquaad I'm a very very very
moving performance let's just leave it
at that
you
[Music]